the first thing the young telegraph
operator noticed was the small black
couch
this was 1935 and sigmund freud who was
still alive had made the psychiatrist's
couch a symbol of psychoanalysis and
therapy but the young man hadn't come to
the office to see a shrink he was there
to see the most famous psychic in the
country edgar cayce casey entered the
room soft-spoken and well-dressed and he
explained that he not the young man
would be the one on the couch so casey
kicked off his shoes laid back and put
himself into a deep trance and after a
few minutes casey began to whisper all
sorts of things about the past present
and the future it was then that the
young man realized that casey wasn't
just making predictions about his life
he was making predictions about everyone
events that were to happen all over the
world and since then edgar cayce has
been called the sleeping prophet let's
find out why
[Music]
edgar cayce was born into a poor farming
family in rural kentucky he was never an
average kid when other children were
outside playing edgar wanted to study
the bible now soon he would take to
wandering into the forest to play with
what he called little folk like peter
dinklage no they were more like fairies
oh
you mean like don't
when edgar was 11 years old he was in
the woods reading his bible when he was
visited by what he called a woman with
wings and the woman asked him what he
wanted most out of life he said he
wanted to help others especially sick
children later that day edgar cayce's
father received a letter from his school
complaining about his son's performance
so his father tested his spelling and
was so upset with how poorly edgar did
he knocked the boy out of his chair and
while on the ground with his ears still
ringing eleven-year-old edgar heard the
voice of the woman in the forest
she told him to lay his head down on his
school book and go to sleep
when he woke up edgar knew everything in
the book like everything he was able to
recite the book word for word so edgar
began studying by sleeping on his books
well by the end of the year he was the
best student in school and even moved up
a grade
his parents were starting to catch on
that something was special about their
son while playing at school edgar
suffered a spinal injury that left him
partially paralyzed and that night while
he slept casey recited the ingredients
for an herbal cure that he said would
fix his injuries now his parents had
nothing to lose so they prepared the
remedy according to their son's
instructions the next morning edgar was
cured when casey was a little older he
developed severe laryngitis doctors
couldn't explain it so casey went to see
a hypnotist yes you do while in a trance
casey said the issue was psychological
paralysis
the hypnotist then directed casey to
increase blood flow to the area
casey's throat turned bright red he woke
up and he was cured casey's fiance told
him that he had a gift that was given to
him by god and he should share it with
the world so edgar casey began
performing readings twice a day on the
sick and injured and in 1902 casey gave
a reading that helped define his legacy
a five-year-old girl had been diagnosed
with a fatal brain injury with nothing
to lose her parents turned to edgar
casey he determined that she actually
had a spinal injury he suggested a
vertebrae readjustment within a few
months she had fully recovered and then
the letters came pouring in for the next
40 years edgar casey gave thousands of
readings and helped countless people but
edgar cayce's talent wasn't limited to
medical diagnoses he made a number of
predictions about future events many of
which have come true and some of them
are terrifying
[Music]
six months before the 1929 stock market
crash casey warned his investor friends
to sell their stocks his friends that
ignored him went broke in 1931 he
predicted that the worldwide economy
would recover in the spring of 1933. did
it it did in january 1934 casey
predicted that hitler would rise in
power and reign over germany hitler
became fuhrer in august of that year and
casey said that hitler would remain in
power until he was overthrown by an
outside war in 1935 casey predicted the
outbreak of world war ii he saw an
alliance between austria germany and
japan but said the war would involve
many nations he also said the united
states would finally enter the war in
1941. casey predicted the deaths of fdr
and jfk and that the united states would
go through a period of civil and racial
unrest in the 1960s in 1938 casey said a
portion of temples may yet be discovered
under the sea near what is known as
bimini off the coast of florida expect
the rising of atlantis in 68 and sure
enough 30 years later in 1968 the bimini
road was discovered in the bahamas
was in the bahamas well if you believe
edgar casey it was i believe he
described atlantis as being an ancient
civilization of equal size to europe and
having superior technology he said that
atlantis disappeared somewhere in the
atlantic ocean some 10 000 years ago due
to a large flood
we now know that every civilization has
a flood myth and in all of them the
great flood occurred 10 000 years ago
when the soviet union was at the height
of its power casey said from russia
comes the hope of the world not in
respect to communism but freedom it will
take years to crystallize but russia
will once again be free in 1991 the
soviet union dissolved and abandoned
communism in 1934 not much was known
about the jewish sect called the essenes
but casey described the sect in detail
and his descriptions were determined to
be accurate he said their records and
documents would come to light and 12
years later the dead sea scrolls written
by the essenes were discovered he
predicted the el nino and la nina
weather events before anyone knew about
them in the 1930s he said the 44th
president of the united states would be
black what number was obama 44. he did
it again and on january 1st 1945 casey
said he would be buried in four days his
wife didn't like this prediction i'm
afraid to ask what happened he died of a
stroke three days later and was buried
in his hometown just as he predicted but
the sleeping prophet's most disturbing
predictions
are yet to come according to casey
the earth is in for a catastrophe that
will reshape continents and rewrite
borders around the world
in 1936 edgar cayce predicted that the
world would undergo a pole shift between
16 and 20 degrees and this would happen
when both mount etna and italy and mount
pele and martinique erupt together when
that happens we'll have 90 days to
evacuate the coastlines are those
volcanoes still active oh they are mount
etna just erupted a few months ago and
scientists at mount pillai said that the
seismic activity there is above baseline
no no
now if the poles do shift as edgar casey
predicts the world map is going to look
very different africa will be divided
into three parts the nile will widen and
a brand new waterway will split the
continent as the red sea grows cairo
will eventually disappear into the sea
asia is already very seismic and will
suffer the most dramatic changes land
will be covered from the philippines to
japan by the ocean as the pacific plate
shifts the islands of japan will sink
leaving only a few small islands taiwan
and most of korea will be completely
lost to the sea the entire coast of
china will be pushed inland hundreds of
miles the population of india will be
told not to seek higher ground within
the interior of the country due to
buckling of the land instead they'll
have to head to the himalayas the high
mountains of tibet and nepal will
provide refuge
antarctica will no longer be covered in
ice but will once again become fertile
and green
australia will lose nearly 25 of its
land due to coastal flooding the
adelaide area will become a new sea the
simpson and gibson deserts will become
fertile farming land new zealand will
actually grow in size and will once
again connect to mainland australia and
new zealand will ultimately become one
of the safest areas in the new world
lucky kiwis europe will suffer
most of northern europe will simply be
gone sunk into the sea as the tectonic
plate underneath it collapses
norway sweden finland and denmark
disappear eventually becoming hundreds
of small islands most of the uk from
scotland to the english channel will
disappear into the ocean but several
small islands will remain london and
birmingham will actually survive but not
as cities as islands ireland will
disappear completely except for land at
high elevation russia will be separated
from europe by an entirely new sea when
the caspian black cara and baltic seas
combine the new sea will stretch all the
way to siberia russia's climate will
remain intact leaving russia to supply
most of europe's food putin is gonna be
king of the world you mean he isn't
already you make a good point in canada
most of the coastline will be pushed in
by 200 miles regions in quebec ontario
manitoba saskatchewan and areas of
alberta will become the refugee survival
center of canada as the north american
plate buckles the new islands of
california will be created with almost
150 separate islands the west coast will
recede east toward nebraska wyoming and
colorado the great lakes and the st
lawrence will join and continue from the
mississippi river all the way to the
gulf of mexico all coastal areas from
maine to florida will be taken over by
water and pushed inland for miles most
of the coastal areas of mexico will be
flooded the california baja coast will
ultimately become a series of islands
billions of people will be displaced by
this cataclysm billions more will be
killed well that was cheerful sorry
about that
when is this pole shift supposed to
happen well casey said 1998 oh we're
fine yeah
but
nasa has detected a slight pole shift
that could be a concern when did they
detect the shift 1998.
[Music]
now to be fair edgar casey has his
detractors he gave over 14 000 readings
so he's going to be right at least some
of the time it's the correct predictions
that make headlines nobody really
notices the things that casey got wrong
casey used expressions like perhaps and
maybe and i feel that rather than using
positive declarations this is a common
technique used by strip mall psychics
this is known as the barnum effect a
common psychological phenomenon where
people tend to accept vague descriptions
as uniquely applicable to themselves
there were many occasions where casey
would receive a letter from a sick
person and then do a reading for them
giving them a diagnosis
casey didn't know that when he was in
his trance the people were already dead
now casey supporters defend this by
saying well if they had applied the cure
while they were alive they wouldn't have
died
okay sure but if casey was talking to
spirits or communing with the universe
or whatever he did
the universe should have given him a
heads up and every time casey got
something wrong there was always a
convenient excuse for example casey gave
the location for a buried pirate
treasure which sent people scrambling
all over the world looking for it no
treasure no casey supporters said it was
possible the ghosts of native americans
or pirates were playing tricks on them
the ghost pirates are pretty sneaky you
cheated
pirate was edgar casey a psychic
i don't really know nobody does and your
case he was never exposed as a hoaxer
and i believe that he saw whatever it is
that he saw and a recent poll surveyed
thousands of american adults of similar
income education and academic
performance and it found that 50 of
people believe in some form of esp or
psychic phenomena what the poll also
found is that people who do not believe
in psychics tend to be more structured
and analytical in their thinking yeah
kids and the people who do believe are
more emotional and creative in their
thinking
well the poll is quick to point out that
believers were gullible and lacked
critical thinking skills now that may be
true to an extent but the poll also
found and this is important that those
quote-unquote gullible believers were
far happier in their lives and had much
lower levels of stress than skeptics
when we talk about psychic phenomena or
the supernatural aspects of religion
these are things that defy scientific
explanation but nobody can deny that
these things provide solace to the
bereaved hope to the unfortunate and
structured to an existence that is
chaotic at best does the supernatural
exist
i don't know i would agree that most
psychics are frauds taking advantage of
people but edgar cayce never took a
penny he really wanted to help people
now whether he was a real psychic or
delusionary i don't think that matters
we need more people willing to dedicate
their lives to helping others we need
more people who see themselves not as
the center of the universe but part of
it part of a larger community where we
have to look after each other real or
not
we need more people like edgar cayce
now more than ever
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
you